the protagonist of the movie is yamabi
takuya a 27 year old man who lives in a
tiny apartment in tokyo alongside his
wife yukari takuya is a web designer by
profession and spends his entire day at
home working on different projects on
the other hand yukari works at a
hospital as a nurse and usually arrives
late at home in this way the lives of
the couple are completely contrasting
takuya doesn't get to go out while
yukari doesn't get to spend much time at
home one night as takuya is busy with
one of his projects yukari arrives home
tired and demands food takuhi was
supposed to prepare dinner but since he
was engrossed in his work he forgot
about it now seeing his wife angry he
gets scared and decides to order food
from his usual delivery app however when
he opens the app it sends a notice that
food deliveries will take a bit more
time due to a large volume of requests
as a result he decides against using the
app he then browses through the app
store for another delivery app and comes
across a new one called otodokemono
strangely the description of the app
mentions that it can deliver the
products in just two seconds as expected
takuya doesn't believe it and thinks it
is a joke but since his wife is hungry
and can attack him at any time he
decides to give otodokimono a try he
orders two cheeseburgers which have
normal rates but the delivery charge is
a bit high at 800 yen we all know that
burned takuya still he finalizes the
order and waits for the delivery
surprisingly the doorbell rings
instantly and on opening a beautiful
girl walks in she is wearing the
otodokimono cap and has the delivery
parcel in her hands taken aback tokuya
questions the girl if she is carrying
the right order but the latter just
hands him the parcel and leaves in the
next scene a still confused takuya
examines the burgers to verify their
authenticity after a bit of sniffing he
concludes that the burgers are real and
that the order is correct just then
yukari comes out of the shower and is
excited to see that the food has arrived
so early takuya mentions that it arrived
in just two seconds but yukari believes
that he said it metaphorically she then
starts devouring the burger and to
takuya's surprise it tastes delicious
later as yukari is doing her evening
facial she notices that her moisturizer
has run out once again she gets angry at
takuya because it was his job to order
the new stuff she chastises him for
failing to do the household chores
despite being at home all day just then
an idea strikes takuya's mind he opens
the otodokemono app and types in the
word moisturizer surprisingly the
product is available and takuya orders
it immediately once again the doorbell
rings instantly and the same girl
delivers the product was she just
hanging out outside the door witnessing
this yukari is left speechless and she
finally believes her husband after the
surreal discovery the couple start
ordering from the app every day they buy
all kinds of stuff food clothes kitchen
items even toilet rolls with time
passing by their lives become heavily
dependent on the otodokimono app one day
the two order some steak and when it
arrives takuya is stunned to find out
that it is from beef and peas american
steakhouse it turns out that there is no
such restaurant in japan and the food
was delivered from the states itself
with this the couple realizes that the
app can even bring them stuff from
different parts of the world they then
decide to make a list of the other
supernatural items that can be delivered
to them at first they try 1 million yen
in cash but the total charge comes out
to be 1 million and 800 yen the
additional 800 being the delivery charge
then they try the iconic one piece's
great treasure but the search engine
sends an error mentioning that the typed
keyword is invalid and they'll have to
watch a thousand episodes first
following this yukari tries a
teleportation door but the search engine
says no results found in this way one by
one all the couple's fantasies are
declined but just then yukari comes up
with an idea she types in the wedding
ring that takuya lost a year ago and
surprisingly the item is available
what's more surprising is the fact that
the total price of the item is still
only 800 yen which is the delivery
charge with this the couple deduces that
the ring takuya bought her was knock off
crap just kidding the couple deduces
that the app can also find lost items
and if it's an item that they already
owned there are no additional costs
wasting no time yukari immediately
places the order and the same girl
arrives at the door in two seconds she
hands them the ring which is exactly the
one that takuya had lost a year ago
following this yukari gets another idea
she types in the word meow which is the
name of her dog she lost 10 years ago
when she was a teenager you'd think
she'd call it bark the plan works and
the app is able to locate the dog in no
time the product is delivered but
strangely it comes inside a box the
couple open it nervously and instead of
a dog they find a pot there they find
the rotting bones of meow and realized
that the dog died long ago despite this
yukari is not willing to give up on her
long-lost friend so she types in the
keyword meow but in a live condition and
orders it surprisingly the dog is
delivered in the same condition that it
was lost in 10 years ago takuya is left
speechless by the phenomenon as he
realizes that the app can also deliver
things from the past in the next scene
yukari is at the hospital she visits one
of her patients mr tsukimoto who seems
to be searching for his watch yukari
approaches him and mentions that he
didn't have any watch when he was
brought in and mr tsukimoto finally
calms down she then advises him to buy a
new one when he is discharged from the
hospital but mr tsukimoto gets angry and
lashes out at her telling her that the
watch was gifted by his late wife as a
keepsake hearing this yukari starts
reminiscing about her dying mother sauri
who had also handed her a locket as a
keepsake the mother expressed her last
wish to see yukari getting married but
the wish was never fulfilled as she
passed away just a few days later i do
not like where this is going at night an
emotional yukari opens the otodokimono
app and types in the words my mother's
salary in healthy condition oh boy
seeing this takuya gets scared and tries
to stop his wife as he believes that the
dead should not be disturbed however
being the stubborn girl that she is
yukari does not listen and proceeds with
the order shockingly the billing amount
totals around 167 million yen despite
this yukari presses the order option but
nothing happens it turns out that the
app will not deliver the things that are
out of the couple's budget the next day
takuya scrolls through the internet and
reads about a famous baseball player
getting married he then types in the
name of the same baseball player in the
otto dokimono app and learns that his
price is around 3.7 billion yen with
this he finds out that a person's worth
is the entire income that they have
earned in their lifetime meanwhile
yukari who is still distraught that she
cannot meet her mother approaches takuya
and tells him that they should stop
using the app being the sensible husband
that he is takuya agrees without saying
a word he should just search jeff bezos
and the apple implode cut to a few
months later the duo has now resumed
their normal lives one day takuya is at
the cinema waiting for his wife to
arrive he soon gets bored and calls
yukari to know about her location when
she mentions that she has just left the
hospital takuya becomes impatient he
then orders the forbidden app and enters
his wife's name to check her worth
surprisingly she is absolutely free and
only the delivery charge is included
here takuya remembers the ring which was
also free since he owned it he then
realizes that though he does not own
yukari since he's not andrew tate she is
still his wife and that makes her his
responsibility after the realization
takuya immediately orders his wife and
bam she's there in the blink of an eye
with this the two start exploiting this
feature of the app more often whenever
yukari finishes her shift at the
hospital takuya just orders her so that
she doesn't have to board the crowded
train they even go on overseas vacations
using the same technique which saves
them a lot of money and time in this way
the couple start living the best
versions of their lives and become very
close to one another in the next scene
yukari surprises mr tsukimoto with his
long-lost watch making him excited he
then promises to help her when she needs
it the most at night it is the couple's
anniversary and takuya has prepared a
lovely dinner for his wife this time he
doesn't teleport her using the app as he
wants to surprise her however when she
doesn't arrive on time he becomes
anxious and calls her he reveals that he
has set up a surprise dinner for her and
asks her to come early but yukari
mentions that she wants to eat at a
french restaurant instead one thing
leads to another and the couple get into
an argument after the call an enraged
takuya opens the otodokimono app and
prepares to order his wife
simultaneously yukari also opens the app
and types in her husband's name they
both press the order option at the same
time and because of a glitch they are
transported to another universe which is
dark and has several doors in it scared
the couple tries to brainstorm several
ways to get out but all of them go in
vain just then takuya takes out his
phone and realizes that it has got
reception he immediately calls one of
his friends and instructs him to
download the same app and type his name
into it however when the friend types in
takuya's name and presses the order
option the total bill comes out to be
200 million yen this is because the
friend does not own takuya so he has to
pay the full amount now with no one to
call for help the couple becomes trapped
in the place forever cut to the next
scene three months have passed and the
couple is still living in the same place
they have used the otodokimono app to
gather all the basic amenities that they
require for living this also includes
the dog takuya is back to his web
designing work but yukari who worked as
a nurse stays idle all day the only
person they meet is the same delivery
girl who works for otedokomono a further
year has passed by and the couple has
started growing distant one day while
takuya is busy with his work meow who
for some reason is still a puppy starts
crying this enrages takuya and he shouts
at the poor puppy he then barges inside
his wife's room revealing that they have
started living separately takuya orders
yukari to take responsibility for the
dog but the latter is uninterested
because of this takuya becomes further
enraged and slaps his wife he quickly
realizes his mistake and tries to
console yukari but she sends him away a
few days later as takuya is working on
his computer an idea comes into his mind
he approaches yukari with a divorce
paper and mentions that if he marries
another girl she can use the app and
order him for free and as soon as he
returns to the real world he will break
up with the girl remarry yukari and
order her back although yukari is
hesitant as she believes that takuya
will betray her and start living with
his new wife she signs the document as
they have no other options the next day
takuya starts his hunt for a suitable
girl he gets a beautiful ring and shows
it to random women online but each one
of them is unwilling to marry him
without meeting him physically upset he
leaves his desk and heads to yukari's
room but surprisingly she is not present
there takuya then searches around the
whole area but yukari is nowhere to be
found he then calls her and gets stunned
to find out that she has returned to the
real world it turns out that she
contacted mr sukamoto for help and he
ordered her via the app by paying the
full amount hopeful that he will now
escape the mysterious place takuya tells
his wife to marry him and order him back
but she refuses instead she mentions
that she is going to marry mr sukamoto
as he is rich and can provide her with a
far better life hearing this takuya is
devastated and he begs his wife to call
him back but she hangs up the call left
with no options takuya opens the
otodokimono app and tries to order his
wife but her new price is over 200
million yen it has been several years
now and takuya is living alone in the
place one day when the delivery girl
arrives with food takuya begs her to
rescue him he says that he would do
anything to get back to the real world
when the girl hears the word anything
she takes him to her workplace which has
thousands of employees who look exactly
like her elsewhere yukari is with mr
tsukimoto and they are living a happy
life the couple also uses the
otodokemono app quite frequently one day
yukari orders a wallpaper for her house
and when the order arrives she is
stunned to see her ex-husband takuya on
the other side with her delivery
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching